this morning in our series we call it
school matters we're taking a look at
racial inequity in education test scores
show the achievement gap between
students of color and their white
classmates widens as high school
graduation approaches Adriana Diaz is at
one high school in suburban Chicago
where a diverse community struggles to
find equality in the classroom Adriana
can't wait for this good morning to you
good morning Gail Oak Park Illinois is
one of those communities that prides
itself on being diverse and progressive
people move here because of that so this
might be where you least expect racial
inequalities at school but as they
explained in a new docu-series some
students who go to school here tell a
different story
one thing about being a kid of color in
the American school system is definitely
just everything is stacked against you
some kids have that mindset growing up
they can be like 10 growing up like the
world doesn't see me as worthy I've
always noticed the racial makeup of my
classes and how being on in more
advanced classes like there are
definitely more white students Charles
Donaldson Brantley and Caroline Roebling
Christ all say racial inequity exists at
their school
where cameras followed them for the
Stars docu-series America to meet
beginning in 2015 a lot of people are
talking about it around the school and I
think like maybe every day like maybe
two to three new people come up to me
Oak Park River Forest High School is in
an upscale and progressive Chicago
suburb that prides itself on embracing
diversity we've seen a lot of films and
a lot of focus on poor besieged
communities public schools with no
funding violence and in the community
but what's going on in a place like Oak
Park where a lot of those more obvious
obstacles to education and equity are
kind of eliminated news director Steve
James is from Oak Park and his three
children went to the school
much of his work explores racism and
adversity including the
critically-acclaimed hoop dreams in 1994
America to me is the first time he's
covered similar themes in his own
neighborhood when you are dealing in a
very liberal community where people feel
like they have a tremendous amount of
self-awareness and sensitivity then it
brings to the fore the ways in which we
are not as sensitive as we may think we
are the series captures universal teen
trademarks who's looking for to 30
getting lost as a freshman and high
school crushes
but phrase in the school's diverse
racial tapestry quickly come into focus
some black and mixed-race students say
they feel like outsiders I knew that the
school wasn't in a sense for me all the
white kids they knowed it they never
have to question whether or not they
should be who in equity also appears in
the numbers white students at the school
scored an average of 33 percent higher
than their black peers on standardized
tests in 2016 what did you think of this
series when you saw it a lot of emotions
principal Nathaniel rouse was against
the docu-series from the start the
school district voted to let the show go
on there is a concern of perception out
there that all of our students are in
our struggling those lived experiences
are real and we need to work on those
but again that's just simply not the
story of all of our students I think
that what is unique about us is our
willingness and attempt to address those
issues with action oriented
opportunities beyond interactions with
teachers America to me also documents
how students interact with each other
whether it's in the lunchroom or certain
clubs of teams like cheerleading to see
it up close and to sort of see in which
the ways in which kids sort of segregate
themselves was eye-opening just being
diverse like some people think all that
solves the problem like all we're all
living together but no you know some
people are living and some are like just
so barely surviving I think the truth is
that racism and supremacy is is no
longer legal so it kind of just happens
behind closed doors and its underlying
but it's still very present even at a
school like this as diverse as this yeah
how do you think school should fix this
kind of problem I definitely think there
needs to be more talks focused on trying
to stop the institutionalized racism and
it's not only in the high school you
need to go back to the home enter school
back to the middle schools because
that's where those things can form and
some people's heads it needs to be
curriculums and things taken place that
can form better equity because I mean
it's never gonna be perfect but we can
least try the students told us they know
these are difficult conversations to
have but that they are necessary to have
they've actually gotten together from
watch parties to view the series
now the students the school and the
filmmaker told us they know that these
issues aren't unique to Oak Park but
they of course plague many parts of the
country John
Adriana thanks and that's what of course
makes it powerful is it's not just a
unique case I thought grant Lee when he
said the world doesn't see me as worthy
- gave me a goose bump and I like
Carolina said listen it still exists we
just don't talk about it and we do have
to talk about it that's that's why I
think something like this is so
important because it makes people so
uncomfortable because no one wants to be
labeled a racist but until you have the
conversation that there are some
differences that that that make us all
unique and that it's okay the
differences are over the
institutionalized racism we've talked
about how these things are systemic they
are pervasive and you don't even realize
that they exist that you're treating
kids differently by some unconscious
bias that you have you have to talk
about it you have to point out the
details in the data that they're scoring
33% unless no white students that's a
problem that's a problem and it is great
to see director - and the filmmaking has
its power because you see what it looks
like when your student of color moving
through a hallway in which you have your
own lane where you are not a part of the
mix but you are and and that is so
powerful to see it and experience it
rather than just here and it's awful to
be in a place and you don't feel part of
the community so she wet that age that's
a very debilitating thing so Bravo -
Charles - grant and Caroline for
speaking up the way they do really smart
kids